pensemos un poco en cómo fluye la
energía y cómo se recicla la materia en
un ecosistema entonces durante este
vídeo vamos a pensar en estas dos ideas
y aún después de ver este vídeo observen
los ecosistemas a su alrededor y de los
que forman parte y piensen en cómo fluye
la energía y cómo se recicla la materia
primero pensemos en la energía la
energía para la mayoría de los
ecosistemas
originalmente proviene del sol hay otras
fuentes de energía podemos pensar en la
luz de la luna aunque esencialmente eso
también proviene del sol o también
existe la energía geotérmica pero para
lo que nos interesa el sol es la fuente
de energía para la mayoría de los
ecosistemas y cómo es que los
ecosistemas usan esa energía como la
obtienen y cómo la almacena
especialmente como biomasa bueno todo
empieza con los productores primarios
que generalmente son las plantas pero
también podrían
las bacterias que tienen la capacidad de
realizar la fotosíntesis es decir de
tomar esa energía y crear biomoléculas
en las que se almacene esa energía
entonces en este diagrama las plantas
son los productores
primarios
aunque también se les conoce como
autótrofos autótrofos obtienen su propia
comida a partir de la energía del sol
pero como almacenan esa energía bueno la
almacenan en las moléculas biológicas si
pudiéramos acercarnos más y observar las
moléculas en esta planta bueno esta es
una enorme simplificación pero podríamos
ver todos estos enlaces entre estos
carbonos y para formar estos enlaces
necesitamos energía y si rompemos los
enlaces podemos liberar esa energía y
tal vez me diga oye y de dónde vienen
todos esos carbonos que están en el
árbol bueno el carbono viene del aire el
aire contiene el dióxido de carbono
estos son los carbonos y estos son los
oxígenos 2 oxígenos por cada carbono y
todo el proceso de fotosíntesis sirve
para fijar ese carbono lo escribiré
aquí se va a fijar el carbón que
inicialmente se encuentra como un gas es
parte del dióxido de carbono y después
se fija en la estructura de la planta se
fija en las moléculas biológicas de la
planta entonces almacena esa energía
ahora este no es un proceso
perfectamente eficiente no toda la
energía del sol se podrá almacenar pues
mucho de eso es reflejado e incluso la
misma planta mientras vive y se
reproduce sus células se dividen y mucha
de esa energía es utilizada y en algún
momento esa energía es liberada en forma
de calor esto lo verán mucho en sistemas
termodinámicos empiezan con una cierta
energía la utilizan para realizar un
trabajo pero en el proceso producirán
calor pero este es solo el principio del
flujo de energía ahora podemos pensar en
cómo esa energía fluye a otros seres de
nuestro ecosistema
vamos a ver en la siguiente fase y este
es un diagrama o mejor dicho un
ecosistema muy simplificado porque la
mayor parte de los ecosistemas son mucho
más complejos pero vamos a pensar en los
seres que se comen a las plantas se
comen a los productores primarios y a
los seres que se comen a los productores
primarios les vamos a llamar
consumidores primarios entonces este
conejito o esta ardilla son consumidores
primarios se comen o mejor dicho
consumen a los productores primarios y
porque los consumen porque el conejo se
come el pasto bueno porque así obtiene
energía de los enlaces entre los
carbonos y de otros enlaces que existen
en las moléculas biológicas y puede usar
esa energía para crecer reproducirse
vivir y correr por ahí y también
almacena un poco de esa energía en su
biomasa pero nuevamente este proceso no
es muy eficiente
al pasar de un nivel trófico a otro solo
se transfiere cerca del 10% de la
energía y esa es la energía que se
almacena en el siguiente organismo y
porque 10% bueno porque no se come a
todas las plantas y porque en todo el
proceso de comer plantas y digerir las
un poco de esa energía se va junto con
el excremento el consumidor primario que
tenemos aquí no pudo digerir todas las
moléculas biológicas
por eso en general es un proceso
ineficiente y bueno aún no hemos
terminado todavía tenemos energía
almacenada en las moléculas biológicas
de este consumidor primario en las que
alguien más podría estar interesado y
sabemos que en muchos ecosistemas hay
seres a los que les gusta comer conejos
o incluso ardillas y en este dibujo
tenemos al zorro y a este zorro que se
come a los consumidores primarios le
vamos a llamar consumidor secundario
consumidor secundario y podemos
continuar con esto si hay algún otro ser
supongamos que aquí hay una persona a la
que le gusta comer zorros y ahí tiene su
herramienta para cazar bueno entonces el
zorro es comido por él y porque come
zorros bueno en realidad lo que quiere
es la energía que hay en ese short y
bueno no se trata solamente de las
moléculas hablaremos sobre la materia en
un momento pero quiere la energía y la
materia del zorro para crecer y vivir
entonces a este ser lo conocemos como
consumidor terciario consumidor
terciario y si no hay nadie que se
quiera comer a este consumidor entonces
es considerado un depredador y todos
estos seres que se comen a otros
animales se llaman carnívoros entonces
este es el depredador y se encuentra
hasta arriba de la cadena alimenticia
pero todavía no hemos terminado porque
en algún punto todos estos seres de los
que estamos hablando es decir los
árboles los conejos el zorro y a este
ser que le gusta comer zorros en algún
momento todos van a morir y esa energía
no desaparece simplemente porque la
energía siempre se conserva y fluye de
un lugar a otro y esa energía será usada
por estos seres a los que llamamos
descomponedores que pueden tomar toda la
energía restante que hay en los
cadáveres o incluso en los excrementos
los descomponen y pueden utilizarlos
para vivir y reproducirse y también al
descomponer los pueden
todos los nutrientes y la materia que se
utilizó con lo que la materia es
reciclada para ser utilizada nuevamente
por las plantas y así es como se crea
este bonito ciclo y lo más importante de
esto es que la energía primero llega en
forma de luz y esa energía es
transferida a través de los diferentes
niveles tróficos y no es un proceso
completamente eficiente porque mucha de
esa energía especialmente mientras estos
organismos viven y se reproducen y
corren por ahí liberan un poco de esa
energía en forma de calor y bueno ya nos
enfocamos mucho en la energía pero ahora
pensemos en la materia la materia es
reciclada y en el caso de la materia no
hay materia nueva que ingrese al
ecosistema al menos no en este ejemplo
la materia no se crea mágicamente ni se
destruye mágicamente y como mencioné
antes cuando observamos una hoja en un
árbol en crecimiento o simplemente un
árbol en crecimiento
o una hoja de pasto en crecimiento esa
materia no aparece de la nada sino que
esa materia siempre estuvo presente pero
en forma de dióxido de carbono
la planta simplemente usa la energía del
sol para fijar el carbono y
transformarlo de la forma gaseosa a la
sólida y puede usar esa energía para
formar enlaces entre los carbonos en
estas moléculas biológicas que almacenan
energía la planta puede usar esa energía
para crecer y como ya dijimos existen
seres que se comen a las plantas o seres
que comen seres que comen plantas y
pueden usar esa energía entonces el
dióxido de carbono se fija en estas
plantas voy a borrar esta flecha porque
así puede confundir un poco bueno
entonces aquí se libera oxígeno o2 ese
oxígeno que es parte del proceso de
fotosíntesis ese oxígeno se utiliza por
los animales para
digerir estas moléculas biológicas
estudiamos eso en biología en
respiración y para la materia miren aquí
tenemos este carbono y cuando es comido
ahora forma parte de las biomoléculas de
este conejito y cuando el conejo usa
cualquiera de esas moléculas biológicas
como una fuente de energía entonces
puede romper los enlaces mediante la
respiración y el carbono es liberado en
forma de dióxido de carbono entonces ya
lo había dibujado aquí bueno entonces lo
más importante a entender es que la
energía fluye la luz del sol entra y
después todo esto ocurre hasta que una
parte es liberada en forma de calor en
la mayoría de las etapas pero en el caso
de la materia siempre ha estado ahí
todos los átomos de nuestro cuerpo y del
planeta tierra son reciclados
constantemente y es materia que se creó
adentro de las estrellas hace miles de
millones de años pero que seguimos
reutilizando
una y otra y otra vez la materia pasa de
una forma a otra aún cuando estos seres
mueren porque los descomponedores
deshacen todo y lo convierten en simples
moléculas inorgánicas que entonces
pueden ser reutilizadas por las plantas
junto con el carbono del aire la luz del
sol y el agua que se absorbe por sus
raíces para empezar otra vez todo este
proceso